and then I went on craigslist and whoa
that's all I say gosh they're people on
craigslist known to create a viral video
and anyone that says to you that can
make a viral video it's gonna be liners
but you cannot reverse engineer a viral
video 72 hours of video uploaded to
YouTube every minute less than three
percent of videos upload to you to go
over 1,000 views hi my name is Dave a
walk and I'm an entertainer living in
Los Angeles I've been given seven
chances to create a viral video this is
my adventure and I invite you to come on
with me can I go viral
can we tell you what took hey I would to
like Tara vogue anko there we go I was
awesome she's so naughty she's so
naughty yeah yeah oh so then on the flip
side you know what was it like for you
getting out of that car moving into a
place our focus is like it was a slow
process so it's like from the car to
like you know like getting a little spot
that somebody's like 'yo cuz you know
how people are listen like people will
tell you like you'll come out and moving
me come stay with me and all of a sudden
like you stay with them for like a week
or two they like you know like this st.
gonna work out now I'm sorry man you
like yeah you gotta leave today like
today you can lead to Davis this is not
like this not like a lot of notice you
know you like I gotta leave today like
this it's not I love no sign of noticed
where where am I gonna like when you
watch those movies and you watched it
like like when you watch the movie when
a person's like you gotta leave in like
you don't get enough notice like this
it's serious cuz you don't know what to
do you like oh my gosh she's like you
started getting a little stuff and it's
so funny because when i started moving
like when i started moving like my spot
and I used to stay at people places it
would be like like like literally like
like a dot on a wall and then all of a
sudden I living with somebody else may
not give me like a little bit something
like a pinkie and all of a sudden would
be like like two fingers and then it'd
be like and then it's taught me like a
hand so your spot started to kind of
like like search like my [ __ ] was like
it was it was it was like I started like
slowly get my own stuff and yet then I
started moving roommates and then you
see what roommates is you just can't
leave anything around your move made you
gotta like put your name on everything
you got even put like even if you have a
girlfriend you gotta be like this is my
girlfriend do not touch like you got put
one of those in there because like
roommates would take your stuff and then
it'd be like look I wanna know what's
your girlfriend bro I'm sorry you didn't
let me know though I mean obviously you
see if you bring her home like you know
like that's what it is it's like
roommates would literally take your
stuff and then tell you like data in
touch it like they'll look at you like
are you
like we don't have coast we don't have
nobody else just me and you you go on
craigslist and the amount of people that
you deal with um I've had I've had some
points where I've met some guys was like
really really super weird really crazy
eye blind roommates um that was cool at
one point we did bump into each other a
lot but it but that's how it is that's
how it is I did have like a nine year
old woman roommate and she looked like
literally you walked in and people
thought she was dead but she was just
watching TV and that's the way she
watched TV she's just like like that was
her look her stone color choose 19 I
remember her but I read them were her we
was on Fairfax I remember that and she
was she was a Russian woman cuz I was
just like a Russian neighborhood listen
it was a sweet offer I doubt don't even
ask it was a sweet offer I I saw this
and this was the area that I really
wanted to live in I was like man I
really want to live in West Hollywood
man because I can party I can drink in
club I can come home you know and just
show and then this woman obviously she
had his posting I was like wow this is
great and then I didn't think it was I
didn't think she was 90 and I was like
wow Lissa's but the place was my spot
but you know said the place is a nice
pine over everything but I did not know
that you know who's gonna be a 90 year
old woman and like I said it was like
the rent was like dirt cheap man's like
five hundred dollars you know I'm
verifies like this is great but I didn't
know it was gonna be sharing my
apartment with her man but you know she
was a little nervous and she was look
obviously she was nervous cuz she's just
thing uh cuz I didn't ever had no I
never had no no credit history you know
I'm said never had a place that credit
history never had a history of like
moving or having a roommate you know one
person I can vouch for was my mom like
you can call my momma you know like she
knows what's up I'm gonna pay groceries
like I'm gonna bring in that head you
know so but living with her was just it
was the scariest thing and I guess
nobody would take up a 90 year old woman
up on that offer you know um but I
like the weirdest thing to like the
weirdest hours should come in almost
half naked breasts hanging all the way
down here in a robe like you want to eat
some ice cream with me or some [ __ ] just
random [ __ ] you just like wow it was a
nice spot I student even had a bag let
me tell you one time one time I end up
getting a bed it took me two years to
get the bed two years for another two
years I only had the bed frame like I
was just sleeping in the bed frame like
I was Dracula like I was like this he
was like dude how do you sleep in the
bed frame join me David war for the next
episode of can I go viral well I was
soon attempt to make a viral YouTube
video